today I'll talk about rocket already
today they're a little over a year ago
in which we try to created video using
data science techniques
hey I did a project together with a ah
who also give the next lecture Netta
yeah and also and if you have any
questions during my talk feel free to
who asked the outline of my talk will be
the hackathon project I'll discuss what
we try to achieve what that is set to we
had but more importantly what data sets
we hadn't and how we compensate it for
it and in the middle I'll discuss about
to a problems of general interest the
one is speaker recognition I mean I have
a audio recording of a person how do I
know which person it is and semantic
sentence similarity in which I have two
sentences and I want to figure out how
close how close is there a semantic
meaning
so let's start the problem we're trying
to solve is there aren't enough Simpsons
episodes
this sounds a bit ridiculous why
Derek when we do the product or 2627
seasons now there are 29 there we have
hundreds of episodes Simpson is actually
one of the longest running series out
there so I'm saying that are in there
aren't enough episodes how can that be
there are a lot of episodes but there
aren't episodes on each and every
subject I want and what do I mean by
that if I want to watch an episode in
which Homer meets his long-lost brother
designs a new car and gets his brother
bankrupt I can Ike there's an episode
like that and I can watch him but if I
invent something new for example Homer
and Marge go bowling and her and Marge
winds and Homer feels really bad about
it himself so he goes back to college
this episode probably wasn't was
introduced so
this is a real problem so I'll go was
given a script to automatically create a
new Simpsons episode
this girl is a bit ambitious and I'll
give you a little spoiler alert we
failed
but we got a lot closer than you would
have expected
so let's start
how do you create a Simpsons episode to
do that we need animation we need to
have the character we need to know how
it moves how it behaves how to look in
the character from each and every side
we need to do this for all the
characters and understand how they
interact with each other have the
background and have the audio synced to
the to the emotion and it is a lot of
this is a lot of hard work but I'm not
an animator I don't know how to do this
stuff I'm a data scientist so I'll use
data scientists there are some
techniques in order to solve this
problem so
what's the idea the idea is to use subs
existing sub scenes as building blocks
for new things and I'll give an example
imagine I write a script and the script
I have Homer saying I want dinner Marge
answered all we have is beer and Homer
answers I love you
this probably didn't appear in any
Simpsons episode but
Homer saying I want dinner might have
appeared in one episode
Marge saying or we have his beer might
have appeared in a different episode and
Homer said I love beer probably appeared
in many episodes
so all I need to do is take these a
little blocks of a video
put them together and I'll have my new
episode
so why do we use Simpsons first of all
it's a great show but more importantly
there is a lot of there there are 20 29
seasons this means that I have a lot of
sub scenes to pick for me but more than
that it's a cartoon so the characters
don't age
and they don't change your clothes this
means that I can take a sub scene from
the second season and glue it together
with a sub scene from that 26 season and
we won't notice the difference
it's something that I just can do with
the with human actors and
moreover is that the speak isn't perfect
because they're cooked their concerns
are not real people and I'll go
into this a little bit later so
how do we start the most important thing
here is to index the scenes I need to
know for each and every sentence the
Simpson said what was said and when
exactly was it said so I need the time
in order to cut the video so where can I
find this data form and we need to cut
the videos well
the simplest the most direct approach is
speech text I have the audios of the of
the episodes I can use my favorite
speech to text program and have the text
itself okay this can work but first of
all speech to text usually has errors
inside so it won't be perfect and more
than that I learn only that we do this
on a hackathon and we had only two days
and this may take a long running time so
we didn't do that we aim so another
option is we can watch all the simpsons
episodes if you watch all the episodes
we can just break down with the
character said time when each character
said it and have exactly that other to
want this is really fun but it does take
a lot of time but what if someone
already did this for us and
someone has and I'm of course talking
about the people who were the subtitles
in the subtitles I have what was said
and in which time exactly it was said so
this is what I need in order to cut the
scenes
there's only one little thing that is
missing here
subtitles don't include the speaker I
know that a this sentence was sent I
don't know which character said it so I
need to company compensate for this
so how will you do it again there are
other options first of all I can use the
text itself if the text says hi I'm Lisa
I know it's the character what the
character is if the text says hi Lisa I
know that the other character in the
dialogue is Lisa
this is possible but it's pretty hard
because the a signal and through the
words is it's pretty weak and the data
isn't really cut into dialogue so it
requires all that works so we didn't
know that
another option is to use the images
itself usually when of character speaks
you can see it on the screen so all I
need to do is create some kind of a face
detection mechanism that will detect the
character and I don't know who the
speaker is this is a really cool
approach but it's a little hard to do it
in hackathon so we didn't do it but
later one of my team members itzá did it
as a side project and you'll hear about
this approach later in the next talk
the third approach is using the speech
the speech itself well the characters
have voices so we can maybe we can
identify the voice
so how how can we do it
first of all we need labelled data
if I have label data I might be able to
train some kind of machine learning
algorithm to recognize the speaker
we did find a few episode that had a
full script and the script we had the
speakers so all we need to do is align
the subtitles with a script and we have
label data okay this is nice
next thing is the training data the
training data is the audio we extract
from the videos but what are the
features how can we define features on
audio that will help us to recognize the
speaker
there are other methods to do this deep
learning is probably the way to go if
you have a lot of time enough processing
power but if you don't have there's
another
method okay it's called male steps and
features and what is this it's basically
a method given an OD signal to extract
features from it
yeah how does it go the first step state
of take the Fourier transform of the
signal basically I have an audio signal
i I do that Fourier transform and get
the frequencies the second part is I met
the parents to the male scale this is
basically a monotone transformation it's
not really interesting its basic what
basically does it moves the units of the
signal to have it closer to the range of
the human voice but we can ignore it
from that because it's not really
interesting the first step as I take the
log of the frequency and then I do a
discrete course in control which is
basically another Fourier transform so
what do we have here Fourier transform a
log and another puritans firm and why is
this useful the raw signal and encodes
information only on the
under voice except how loud it and that
that is a very weak signal to identify
the speaker if I do the for F for the
first Fourier transform what I get is
the frequencies and we know that
frequencies have much more information
about the speakers for example women
tend to talk with high pitch and a male
tend to talk to Klobuchar so this is
better but the third power is after I do
the same fret and firm it's basically
the frequencies of the frequencies or
you can think about it as how the
frequencies change this has information
that's regards to the vocal cords and
the throat and it's basically a
signature of the onion Jiali of the
speaker and this has a lot of
information
calculating this is a bit tricky so
Python to the rescue and we can't let
pip install our packet Python speech
features
we read the wav file we run the MFC
ciara function and we have the features
that's it really really simple
cool so now we have the features we can
define the features on small time frames
we can run the prediction on each and
every time frame and combine the
predictions and using a multi-class
logistic regression we got around 80%
accuracy on four labels the labels are
Homer Marge Lisa and Bart Meggie doesn't
speak so we're no labels for a for her
cool so now we know the speaker but we
encountered another problem there isn't
enough data and what do I mean by not
enough data if I want
my characters to say a specific sentence
the sentence doesn't necessarily appear
in my data set so what can I do I have
two approaches you the first approach is
you spective speech well the if the
sentence doesn't appear I can generate
the voice of the character and just put
it on the episode but this is tricky why
because I need to choose which video I
want to use so if I want a sentence with
five words I need to find
that when the characters said said the
sentence with five words and I want the
length of the words to be similar in
both sentences and maybe I want a vowels
in the words in this and the world to be
similar so this this disciplines can
work the problem with it is that we all
know the symptoms we all know how to how
they sound so if we will use
text-to-speech the characters will sound
different and and a natural so what did
you get instead we decided not to use
the exact sentence want but find the
most similar sentence in our training
set
so now we have another problem how can
we define two sentence that have similar
semantic meaning
okay for that we'll use something else
called the word move or distance it's
related to the person for distance if
you're familiar with it and it's
basically this idea
assume we have two sentences Obama
speaks to the media in Illinois and the
president's greeted the press in Chicago
the first thing I do is I swear out all
the staff words the staffers are those
little words that don't convey in
meaning like to the M so we throw them
away now we take the remaining words and
we project them using words of X under
embedding and under embedding space
what do we know about the embedding
space in the abandoned space if we have
a two words with similar semantic
meaning they'll get too close vectors
so how can i define the distance between
the two and between the two air
sentences I'll just add the distance
from Obama to president from speaker
sticks to grips from Illinois to Chicago
and firm media to press I'll sum the
distance set up and this will be the
distance between these two sentences
this isn't that simple why because in
this example I knew that I want to match
Obama to president but I don't really
know that in the beginning
so this is actually an optimization
problem an application problem that I
need to true with which a word to pass
to which word and this can be
defined as a linear program and solve
very efficiently and
if I have a different number of words in
the centum said it's still no problem I
just wait the words accordingly and it
works the same so now we have an example
I have two sentences Obama speaks the
median in night and the band gave a
concert in the pan and I wanted to see
which of these sentences is the closest
to the president's greet the person sick
Ricardo so I compare a Obama to
president and the distant at 0.45 and
the band to president is 0.49 speaks to
Greece is 0.24 and smashed close so that
gave to read with a 0.42 and do this for
all the words and sum up and I can see
the big one is closer to the 0 then B 2
so I conclude the D 1 is closer
semantically to the 0 so if I need to
treat one of them I choose the one
something really nice about this method
ok before that and how do we implement
this and again Python to the rescue and
Jenny Singh and the package has a very
nice model to calculate this and how
does it work I have two sentences I do a
very simple prayer processing which is
basically lower to the case and to throw
away stop words I
need to load my embedding file there's
there are a lot of files I can download
and
calculate model in CUDA words move the
distance between the two sentences
that's it really simple one thing I like
about this metal it has no hyper
parameters and it works very well out of
the box here are examples we use we try
to look for go to bed and we found go to
sleep and your father said eat your
carrot your mother said eat your
broccoli we had lunch and we had dinner
you missed lunch you missed breakfast
and we can see that the world the
sentences have similar meanings which is
really really nice
ok we're getting towards the end
and I remind you that it was a hackathon
project and we were running out of time
and one of the things we encountered was
that if we use the speaker recognition
our data basically cuts gets cut by
85% why because if I want Homer to say a
specific sentence I need to classify all
the sentences and find only when Homer
said it and Homer as there are four
characters and some other characters so
basically I lose 85 percent of the data
for the speaker recognition and we
didn't really have the entire and 27
faders we had two and a half
so we decided to ignore the speaker and
to do something else it we call it
Simpson style of text and what do I mean
by that that's given in the text see how
the Simpsons would have said it and for
that and we used we asked out from the
one and only
Britney Spears and I'll show you the
demo and what we'll see here is Brittany
singing hit me baby one more time but
after each line Berkley sings we find
one of the Simpsons characters says the
sentence which has the
the lowest the highest semantic
similarity to what Britain in the Sun
okay
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
could you tell me how it works
[Music]
tell me everything
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
and questions oh
that's a wonderful questions and the
question was in the Simpson there they
have several verse actors that dub the
same characters and this is right but
I've tracked it and the four main
characters are narrated by different
people so it's okay but very good
question and shows a lot of familiarity
with the Simpson
thank you
[Applause]